March is here fellow witches and
warlocks and that means it's only one
month away until the chilling Adventures
of Sabrina is back and we can finally
continue down that path of night so what
can we expect from the upcoming season
and yes I know it's technically part two
but it gets confusing so whatever the
showrunners have been pretty
tight-lipped but I've got a few leads
that you're not gonna want to miss now
if you haven't checked out part 1 the
rest of this video will contain spoilers
so be warned and if you'd like a
refresher you can check out my breakdown
videos for the entire first season as
well as the teaser breakdown for part
two first of all we can speculate that
the events of season two take place
shortly after the ending of season 1
Susy Roz Harvey in the gang are still
attending Baxter High and take a look at
this interview Kiernan Shipka did with
Bloody Disgusting back in October I
would just say that without giving too
much away because it would be a bit of a
spoiler the way that Sabrina's life
takes certain turns in certain decisions
she makes inform the second season the
finale of the first season sets up a lot
at the end of part 1 you'll remember
that in order to save her mortal friends
Sabrina signs the book of the beast and
becomes a full-blown witch the show
establishes early on that once this
happened Sabrina will have to sever ties
with the mortal world including her best
friends Roz Susy and boyfriend Harvey
kinkle but throughout season 1 Sabrina's
determined to find a way to walk both
the paths of night and the path of light
to be both mortal and a witch with the
signing of the book of the beast however
you might think Sabrina's been forced to
put her mortal life behind her well not
so fast we obviously know that Sabrina's
mortal friends are still included in
part two based off the teaser but take a
look at this Instagram post from
Michelle Gomez aka our very own madam
Satan it's one of the few Instagram
posts from a cast member that actually
shows an image from season 2 and I'm
getting huge school play vibes here
seems like something that's more likely
to be taking place at Baxter high as
opposed to the Academy of unseen arts
especially with mrs. Ward well who
despite her title as mother of demons
still teaches at Baxter high so expect
to see Sabrina's still spending tons of
time in the mortal world which also
makes sense considering hilda and her
budding relationship with dr. Cerberus
who everyone assumes is immortal
which reminds me where else it's good
segue in my teaser breakdown video in
season one ending explained I speculated
that dr. Cerberus is actually a werewolf
we got that image of his crazy eyes at
the end of the season as well as a
glimpse of a werewolf and Sabrina clad
in her best Little Red Riding Hood
cosplay not to mention there's also a
shot of a full moon so wouldn't be too
far of a reach to expect werewolves on
the prowl in part two and it appears
that he'll does not the only one getting
a new bow this season we've learned of
at least two new additions to the cast
including Alexis Denisof who you might
remember from Buffy the Vampire Slayer
angel or as sandy rivers from How I Met
Your Mother
looks interesting next season he'll be
playing Adam masters a doctor who
returns to Greendale to find that his
fiancee Mary Ward will yes that mrs.
Ward well he's not quite the same person
she used to be the other addition is
Jedediah Goodacre who will be playing a
warlock named Dorian Gray an enigmatic
gentleman of an indeterminant age who
owns a nightclub
perhaps the nightclub scene here of note
is the name Dorian Gray which is based
off the Oscar Wilde novel the Picture of
Dorian Gray Dorian the character is the
epitome of beauty youth and sensuality
so much so that an artist becomes
infatuated and paints him Dorian ever
obsessed with maintaining his youth and
beauty sells his soul so that the
pitcher and not he will age I imagine
the Dorian Gray from Sabrina will follow
a similar kind of storyline the final
clue we have for season two lies in the
comic book adaptations of Sabrina now we
can't expect to see everything from the
comics appear in the show as we know the
Netflix adaptation has strayed quite far
from its comic book inspiration for
example in part one in the comic Harvey
kinkle gets eaten by witches part two of
the comic which I will add isn't
complete yet revolves around the
mysterious return of Edward Spellman who
wonders who could have possibly helped
Sabrina
become such a powerful witch aka mrs.
ward well my speculation is that just
like with the resurrection of Harvey and
Tommy kinkle the show will take from the
comic but not exactly now it's possible
that Papa Spellman could resurface soon
but my theory is that the Edward
Spellman character from the comic will
actually be mirrored in the show with
Adam masters masters realizing the
his fiancee is a little more demonic
than usual we'll set in course a series
of events that leads to the exposure of
who mrs. Ward well actually is so that's
my big speculation for season 2 that by
the end of the season Sabrina will
finally find out what mrs. Ward wells
been hiding from her oh and one last
thing for all you wondering if we'll
ever hear Salem speak again there's hope
yet according to an article from
indieWIRE show creator Roberto
aguirre-sacasa said when we did the show
he doesn't speak partly to project the
horror tone that isn't to say that Salem
won't talk in the future he also states
we've definitely talked about doing a
Salem centric episode where we could
learn more about his life considering
how we saw stola speak at the end of
season one I'd say there's a good reason
to believe our little feline friend
might be chatting sooner rather than
later
so that's it for this video I'm super
excited to check out what season two of
Sabrina has in store for us in just a
month if you enjoyed this video give it
a like and subscribe and be sure to keep
your eyes peeled as I'll be making an
ending explained video on season 2 when
it comes out and remember daddy loves
you very much